you'd be forgiven for thinking that this
was an ordinary squirrel
this is ratatoskr the mischievous
messenger of Norse mythology ratatoskr
was tasked with carrying messages from
the gods along the world tree Ignacio
however the squirrel like to gossip and
he would often put his own spin on
messages in some depictions the
character of ratatoskr was shown to
despise the world tree and seemed intent
on destroying the tree of life as he
lacks strength an ability to do much
damage himself instead manipulates
others into attacking the tree for him
in some variations of the tale ratatoskr
is shown to have elongated ears but
other than that he looks very similar to
an ordinary red squirrel he would
regularly carry messages to the wise
eagle who sits at the top of the
Yggdrasil and the serpent nidhogg who
lives coiled among the tree's roots a
ratatoskr would ferry insults between
the eagle and nidhogg the eagle did not
take kindly to this and vowed vengeance
against the dragon it was because of his
trickery that the Eagle and knit hawk
formed a serious hate for one another
bowing to destroy each other when the
Ragnar came in patient and I'm willing
to wait ratatoskr continued to feel the
hatred between the two until one day
nidhogg began Noren at the roots of the
tree in hope that the tree would fall
and crush the eagle when the ratatoskr
returned with news of net Hawks plan the
Eagle began to pluck branches from the
tree and rein them down on nidhogg it
was not destroyed as he hoped but
ratatoskr succeeded in doing great
damage to the Tree of Life
it is believed that no God knows
ratatoskr as well as Loki which makes
sense considering they are both
tricksters of sorts if you've enjoyed
this video then please consider leaving
a thumbs up as it helps promote the
video and allows the channel to grow if
there's anything you'd like to discuss
or have any ideas for future videos then
please let me know in the comment
section as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explained